debugging is easily one of the most
annoying and frustrating aspects of a
programmers life in this episode I'm
going to cover seven different
techniques that you can use to debug
angular for application hopefully this
will save you some time and frustration
as you build your app the great thing
about angular is that it uses typescript
by default which prevents many of the
bugs that collect JavaScript
applications it does this by allowing
you to write JavaScript code with static
typing as opposed to dynamic typing this
just means you define the data types and
properties of objects before they're
actually used in the code so why is this
beneficial well the number one reason is
it allows your text editor to give you
instant feedback whenever you're about
to introduce a bug into your code take a
look at this code here it's more or less
just plain JavaScript and it opts out of
all of typescript strong typing features
an animal should always be an animal
object but what if we define it as a
string will we get an error in this case
we don't because an animal variable can
be assigned to any data type so we've
introduced a bug in this code we
wouldn't actually see it fail until run
time the same thing goes for function
arguments say this function should
always have a number and a string we get
passes other data types but it still
won't fail until it reaches run time now
let's see how we can use typescript to
prevent these bugs in the first place so
we create an animal class that has these
properties strong type is a number and a
string then when we declare the animal
variable we can set it to this animal
datatype ensuring that it's always a
JavaScript object with these exact
properties when we define the function
we can set data types on the arguments
to ensure that we can't accidentally
pass the wrong datatype to it and we can
also force this function to always
return an instance of the animal class
so we can't accidentally return the
wrong value from the function so now
let's try to use this code and see the
difference in the feedback we get from
the text editor if we call the function
with the correct data types everything
is all good there's no error but if we
try to turn the number into a string
we'll get instant feedback that this is
the wrong data type so instead of
waiting for this code to fail at runtime
we know we've introduced a bug and know
exactly how to fix it here the cool
thing is we'll get feedback about
properties that exist on an object so if
we try to call a certain function or
property we know exactly
what's their based on the feedback we
get from typescript if we try to call a
property that doesn't exist we'll get an
error from typescript and our code won't
compile in my opinion typescript is the
single most important tool you have for
debugging angular applications the next
debugging tool we'll look at is the
debugger statement from JavaScript a
debugger statement will stop the
execution of JavaScript which
essentially allows you to pause your
application at any point to inspect it
in this example we have a component and
we're going to add a debugger to the
constructor and also inside of an rxjs
subscription now let's go to the app and
see what happens when it hits that
constructor it pauses the app right here
and brings up the file that we're trying
to debug then we can hit the play button
and it'll once again pause the
application when it hits that
subscription this can be very useful
when you're not sure exactly which
component or service is causing the bug
the next debugging tool we'll look at is
the JSON pipe this is something you can
use to inspect data directly in the HTML
it's especially useful when you're not
sure exactly what an object looks like
after retrieving it from a database or a
third party API if we go into the app we
can see that we're now seeing all the
properties in this item listed in JSON
format now let's look at some of angular
is built in debugging tools to enable
them we'll need to make some adjustments
to the main TS file after we bootstrap
the app we'll have to enable debug tools
on the app component itself check out
the link in the description to just copy
and paste this code the first thing
we'll do is use ng probe which allows us
to extract information from a component
in the Dom so we do that by clicking on
the component itself first in the HTML
then we can use ng probe dollar sign 0
and that will give us this debug element
back which has a bunch of information
about the component itself
the other cool thing we can do is run a
change detection profile which should
happen very fast in this case it only
takes point zero five milliseconds per
change detection cycle now let's take a
look at the augury plugin for chrome if
you don't already have this installed go
to the Chrome Web Store and get it
installed today it's free and very
powerful it gives you a visual picture
of the apps components and services so
you can easily debug things like sharing
data between child and parent components
as well as dependency
Injection with services it also gives
you a visual breakdown of your router so
you can see exactly which components are
being imperative leet loaded and lastly
it gives you a breakdown of your ng
modules this is a lot more efficient
than looking at each file individually
another strategy for debugging is to
create your own custom logger this
allows you to prioritize and customize
the errors that you see in your app
install it by running NPM install
angular 2 - logger import it into the
app module and it's a service so we'll
add it to that providers within that
module then we can inject it into a
component just like any other service
and start logging messages with various
priorities in this case we'll do an
error and a warn message and if we go
into the console we can see we get these
two different messages with different
priorities and last but not least let's
talk about debugging rxjs observables RX
has a do operator that allows you to
execute code within the observable chain
without creating any side effects or
impacting the underlying observable in
this example we're retrieving an object
observable from firebase and then first
we're going to just console.log it then
we're going to map it down to a string
and then we'll console.log it once again
using the do operator so the do operator
basically allows you to throw in any
kind of debugging code you want within
your observable as your mapping or
filtering it when we subscribe it will
trigger the code inside these new
operators in the app we can see we first
get a console log object and then we get
that mapped down to an uppercase train
afterwards
that's it or angular debugging if this
video helps you please like and
subscribe and if you want to support the
channel consider becoming a pro member
at angular firebase comm you'll get a
free copy of my book as well as one on
one project consult team designed to
help you get your app shipped into
production thanks for watching and I'll
see you soon
[Music]